often solving mathematical problems
requires a certain state of mind
do you find yourself going through
periods where you feel like
your mind is not creative enough not
focused enough and how do you
solve that yeah of course well you just
have to go off and do something
else so um
there are several things you can do for
this i mean john conway told me that
that what he
he did is he always had a sort of
background calculation so he'd be
calculating tables of knots or
tables of lattices or something you can
you you can do that even if you're not
feeling inspired and
i think richard feynman had this idea
that you could always do teaching as a
sort of background
thing and the point in both cases is so
that you have
something where you can see that you're
making progress because the i mean
the trouble with research is most of the
time you're
you're working hard and making no
progress at all and this is
psychologically kind of a bit depressing
so you need to have something something
else you can do where you can actually
make visible progress on it
what's the longest lull or the longest
involuntary cognitive hiatus you've
experienced
well i'd say um hard to say i mean it
might be now um i've been working on a
problem for
several years and i
i i don't know what the progress is
because you know 20 times i think i've
solved it and got really excited
and and then i start to write a top and
geez there's this huge hole i somehow
overlooked so i go back to being
depressed for a bit and
and so it keeps on switching backwards
and forwards between thinking i solved
and thinking i haven't and i
you know i i sometimes think that that
sooner or later i'm going to be
get so senile that i can't actually
figure out what's wrong with my solution
and then i can publish it
and you know you know the the the the
this is what this is actually
unfortunately what happens to some
mathematicians when they get old
they sort of lose this capacity to see
what's wrong with what they're doing